the next body type we're going to talk
about is going to be called the adrenal
now the adrenal gland sits on top of the
kidney right here you got two of them go
ahead and put your fingers on your
adrenals now the adrenal gland is a
stress gland how many of ever
experienced stress before got one two
three four five six give me an example
what stresses people out work traffic
children kids husbands being overweight
school relationships like finances well
you guys can relate to that how many of
ever had a stressful relationship before
at least once twice okay we'll stop
right there
so the adrenal reacts and adapts the
body to stress so if you pretend like
you're being chased by a tiger for the
next ten years and how your body would
react to that that's what happens with
the adrenals over time when it burns out
well if you're being chased by a tiger
you're not going to able to sleep okay
you're not gonna be able to reproduce so
you're going to have problems with
hormones reproductive hormones you're
going to problems with digestion
you're gonna problems with blood
pressure and cholesterol on all these
other things with blood sugars because
you're running on sugar so I'm going to
go through all of them but the adrenals
regulate stress and stress does
accumulate yes you're like a bucket and
you filled up in fact there is always
some stress that has occurred right
before you started developing a stubborn
weight issue always if you ask a person
they think it's just calories right well
if you take it back when did you start
gaining weight what happened just before
that you're going to find that they had
a baby
c-section a surgery a hysterectomy tubal
ligation they got married they got a
divorce on that same date now now they
have just a lot of different stresses
I've had people even as kids be be
overweight and many times it comes after
an asthma attack or a sore ear infection
or a throw
the infection so many things that can
stress the body out but stress does
accumulate and over time you develop too
many applications on your desktop
computer which is your body so all these
things accumulate and you're just like a
bucket of stress you're kind of some
people when we measure the inside of you
are so jacked up they can't sleep they
can't relax so I would say probably the
biggest thing that stress is people out
are other people is that true there's
certain personality types that kind of
get to you
you got the whiner right there like when
you please help me when you please help
me do the ever accept your help now you
just want to help you just want to like
okay let me push you downstairs now do
you want my help so it's like you have
whiners you have the antagonistic person
who's rude you have the real depressed
person that brings you down you'll give
them a solution they say now that will
never work or you have those really
happy people that are always this happy
that doesn't stress me up but sometimes
it's like if you're depressed you don't
really like these happy people they're
just too positive all the time but
there's one personality type that really
gets on my nerves and they call it the
passive-aggressive called under minors
now let me show you what they what they
look like so everyone look at me very
very hostile right now you're smiling
look at me very mean okay now smile hi
nice to meet you they're gonna backstab
you to your face they told you they
stood up for you but they actually ruin
your reputation
they love gossip I don't even know
anyone like that they give you a
compliment but they follow it up the
sharp critical comment they'll say
something like hey that's a nice jacket
was it on sale like who would ever say
that psycho that's a nice haircut did
you get at cheap cuts my uncle I mean
actually yes it was my uncle he goes
congratulations you graduated as a
chiropractor
gratulations hey why don't you want to
become a real doctor
so you have people that are bringing you
up and people are bringing you down
right so those people they bring you
down covertly so they're very
introverted they'll they'll do something
like this are you feeling okay you look
really tired are you sick
and you're like I was fine until you
said that so I do have a way of getting
back at these people if you'd like to
know about that anyone want another
technique
okay just reverse the flow just do back
to them have you has that been growing
for a while you don't have anything in
the face they'll be in the bathroom for
hours looking at their face going is
there anything on here because they're
introverted you so yeah okay so let's
move on to something less stressful but
if you're in a relationship like that or
someone's connected and you're trying to
reason with them don't hold your breath
you can't reason with them that's what
frustrates you because you just want to
get them to see can't you see that
you're crazy now they're not going to
see that they have to be right they'd
rather be right then successful so you
just better off just ignoring them okay
so adrenal when the adrenal gland gets
burnt out your tolerance for stress goes
down you don't tolerate people anymore
people get on your nerves you become
edgy especially incompetent people
people make mistakes you kind of like
you might react more than you should
right you're not going crazy okay
it's the adrenals because the tolerance
of stress you ability to tolerate stress
stuff this kind of buffers it so
sometimes that buffer goes down and
you're and you're just kind of on edge
all the time the way you think it's not
linear it's like popcorn thoughts just
come in like this your memory starts the
adrenal affects the GPS in the brain so
it's kind of like you're going on stairs
you're like calm what am I looking for
again I've got a backtrack okay you'll
be talking to some of it you're actually
having another conversation in your head
you might be waiting for the person to
stop talking so you can talk because
you're kind of thinking too fast it's
going too fast what you're doing you're
solving problems 24/7
you can't stop solving problems in fact
you can't stop thinking so with the
adrenal they do a lot of thinking and
because they're in a survival mode it's
called flight or fight mode that is a
the problem with that is it stirs up the
adrenals even more what they should be
doing is just turn it off for at least i
don't know like a half hour a day go for
a walk look at a tree a bird a cloud and
just get space don't get the headphones
on and you know look at your computer
all the time how many of you sit in
front of a computer more than five hours
a day 16 hours a day Wow
that what happens is that it really kind
of the computers everything kind of will
stress your body - especially if you
have the computer right next to your
body I would try to get as far away as
possible and even when you go to sleep
at night make sure there's no electrical
stuff right by your head you got cell
phones you know all that stuff I'm very
sensitive to energies and I can pick up
like I don't like talking in that cell
phone somehow it just like feels like
there's a microwave in my brain so I'm
like okay I gotta go you know just
that's why everyone's like what's your
cell phone number I never pick it up
because I don't like that cell phone so
the adrenal when the adrenal gets
stressed you can't tolerate stress and
you start increasing hormones that are
going to cause belly fat all right so
this is an adrenal body type shape right
here the weight is right there now why
is it in the belly primarily because
your body's in survival and as a stress
mechanism you're going to hold it around
the most important organs which happen
to be in your midsection your body's
trying to survive it's trying to help
you it's protecting you against
starvation that low-calorie diet that
you're going to go on yeah so it's like
going to put it right here how many
sit-ups will it take to flatten that
belly it's not going to happen why
because it's coming from a hormone your
problem is not your weight it's your
hormones
you have to reduce that cortisol the
things that people do to lose weight end
up destroying their metabolism and their
hormones we don't want to Jack that up
anymore so people take stimulants
you're already stimulated you don't want
to jack it up more so it goes there now
over time instead of burning the belly
fat off as energy it's going to burn off
your leg muscles before it even touches
that fat in other words your body is
going to use up your proteins and your
little in your thighs so guess what
that's connected to your knees that's
why you have a lot of knee problems with
with adrenal and you have a lot of
collagen because all the the glue that
holds about it together falls apart so
you have loose skin
it's called pendulous abdomen it kind of
sags right here and when you get it from
a seated position you kind of like
getting up climbing is a problem your
legs are heavier don't where it gets
worse so after these legs become
dissolved then your adrenals will go
after another muscle called a glutinous
a Maximus what muscle is that you're
behind so so what happens is not only do
we get us thinner legs and bigger trunk
but we get no butt so you got no butt no
legs all belly you've seen people like
that right so you have somebody look
forward to I'm telling you you got it
you have to gotta start now just
preventing okay I've had relatives that
before menopause oh my goodness waist
like this after like that so yeah so
adrenal glands will cause all sorts of
problems with stress responses and it
affects their ability to sleep normally
when you go to sleep at night you're
supposed to go through four waves of
sleep from a light sleep here to a deep
sleep here now down here in the lower
parts this is called the Delta wave
sleep right here that's where you burn
90% of all your fat not during the day
all the fat burning
kurz right there if you're not sleeping
you're not going to burn fat but in your
mind you're thinking you're wasting your
time I should be walking while I'm
sleeping just to burn off those calories
so let's talk about calories for a
second
yes exercise does burn calories that's
true
but not necessarily fat calories let's
take a look at something when a normal
person exercises they they actually
stress their body out okay it sounds
pretty interesting but what all the
benefit from that exercise occurs in the
recovery 14 hours to 24 hours later when
you're in the deep sleep if you're
sleeping if you let yourself recover you
ever hear that workout called the p90x
or the insanity workout I know I'm gonna
see people like 45 they start doing that
you ever see the videos they have like
18 year-olds if you have low recovery
like low endurance low fitness and you
do that something that hot you're going
to hurt yourself you're going to pull a
hamstring I see it all the time
my son I took them to wrestling practice
and he's like 16 17 I was wrestle in
college we go there and all the father's
are and around the mat they're standing
around the perimeter with their shoes
off with her socks on waiting to jump in
there because they're in their mind
they're still 18 one guy breaks the rib
this guy you know he runs out of almost
like had a heart attack it was hilarious
so mentally you might still be 18
physically you may not be quite that
level so it really all the benefit
occurs in the recovery after the workout
so when you exercise you stress your
body and then you're supposed to recover
and that's when you burn the fat not
during the workout if you don't believe
me go work out three hours and weight
yourself before and after you'll burn
900 calories let no actual weight loss
okay so it's all right here if you can
recover adrenal cases don't recover that
well so they don't adapt so the exercise
only as good as if you can change or
adapt to it
so that's really what we're dealing with
this how do you get your body to change
from the things you're doing it how many
thumb when you're 18 you can pretty much
eat anything you want really you can
just get away with it right
how many fun you can't quite get away
with it now what is the difference the
difference is your metabolism the rate
your metabolism okay that's really
what's broken
you really have to exercise based on
your ability to recover from it it's
better off for adrenals if you go
walking on a flat surface than to get on
that treadmill to burn off the calories
so the thing that people do cut calories
starvation exhaustive exercise is the
exact thing that's keeping that weight
there and they're frustrated because
they been taught that oh everyone knows
that you just have to exercise and diet
oh really well those people are saying
that have never probably worked with one
person I bet I've been there in the
field of weight loss for 25 years I
worked on 35,000 different people I
believe a patient because I observe them
they're eating good and it's still not
working
they're doing the treadmill still not
working so it really has to do with the
internal so we want to adjust the
workout to your ability to adapt that's
why you have to you can't put everyone
in the same program everyone needs their
own program so with adrenal either they
can't get to sleep because they're so
wound up and they can't relax because
they're thinking so much or they get up
in the middle of night right - and just
like they're more awake at 2:00 than
they are turning the day in fact right
after lunch
or 3:00 o'clock they're just ready to go
to sleep so you can't get to sleep you
can't stay sleep or the bladder which
actually is controlled by the adrenal
has to eliminate you know so they're
getting up urinating several times a
night
that's adrenal the best sleep for the
adrenal is a half hour before the alarm
clock goes off right there right when
you finally get to sleep that's when you
got to get out there can anyone relate
to that yeah don't worry it gets worse
so we got the adrenal will affect the
sleep create an inability to see change
from a workout and it also will
act your cognitive it affects a lot of
other things as well it affects blood
pressure yeah that's one of the symptoms
from the adrenal is high blood pressure
especially of the top number the
systolic before the diastolic so always
look at the top number if the top top
note is high we know it's adrenal so
because your body's you lost that
recovery mechanism to kind of keep the
pressure down so you have blood pressure
we have blood sugar yes
diabetes is a symptom of adrenal because
they control the sugars blood
cholesterol is adrenal yeah
cholesterol is needed to make adrenal
hormones during stress the more stress
you go through the more cholesterol you
need to be able to build those hormones
and then you have all allergies our
adrenal including this sinus low vitamin
D levels are hard renal yeah I know your
doctor saying go take vitamin D
deficient but they're not asking why
okay arthritis all the itis ha's in fact
anything connected with inflammation is
adrenal poor handwriting and that's me I
could write the first part of the word
but the last purchase kind of gets all
lost so what this means blood pressure
blood sugar blood cholesterol oh geez
vitamin D inflammation and cognitive
issues and some now other than that
you're perfectly healthy now here is the
problem what happens is that the medical
system treats treats these they don't
ask why there's no evaluation what
they'll do is take that symptom okay
these are symptoms this is what symptom
is and then they make it the problem
okay they confuse the symptom with the
problem it's like one of those obvious
things I'm like is it just me why isn't
anyone asking this question because if
you ask your doctor what caused this
what they'll do is convert it to a very
scientific complex name okay you
Lum Belgium was that meaning low back
pain okay you have fibromyalgia what
does that mean you got you're hurting
all over your body you have plantar
fasciitis what does that mean you got
pain in the foot you have dis data
Kinesis sounds pretty scientific that
means you can't do this with your body
you can't rotate it back and forth you
have spawned a little thesis what does
that mean you have a you have a broken
back there's all these labels
post-traumatic stress syndrome you means
you you got some stress in your past
they have one now called non-compliance
to treatment disorder I'm serious I'm
not kidding non-compliance to treat mis
order if you don't do what the doctor
says I told my son that and he said Oh
homie don't play that I'm like I said I
said what does homie don't play that
mean he said that means I'm not going to
do what you say like okay then you're
going to get a diagnosis from the doctor
because he's going to go you have
non-compliance the treatment story well
maybe you didn't want the surgery maybe
you want to suck opinion and they'll put
this label they have manic-depressive
what does that mean it means that you're
happy and sad what's wrong with being
happy you know you have a clinical
depression it could mean that you're not
sleeping people that don't sleep get
depressed so it's just amazing and then
it's treated with a poison I'm sorry of
medication my whole thought is that
what's really missing in healthcare is
the health part it's kind of like that I
mean I don't know that sometimes I'm
like did I just think of that is that
original idea or does everyone know that
I mean it's bizarre there's no health
and health care it's all disease care
there are underlying principles to all
subjects in life that are very high
principles that everything kind of must
revolve around okay my whole principle
and weight loss is getting healthy lose
weight not losing weight to get healthy
you have to focus on your health now
that's pretty powerful because if you
don't know that you're very susceptible
to the next unhealthy diet that comes
along or a little gimmick that
might not be healthy but if you look at
it from the viewpoint of okay is that
healthy yes okay that might work let's
just take the word food how many of you
eat food okay yeah how many of you never
looked up the definition of the word
food before okay I'm going to tell you
what it is is that which is eating to
sustain life provide energy promote the
growth of a pair of tissue it comes from
the Latin word which means nourishment
nutrients so food is nutrients that's
why we supposed to eat we're not
supposed to eat food for necessarily
anything other than health and nutrients
but so when you go into the grocery
store you can ask now what am I in the
mood for no no no don't ask that because
you're going to get a brownie but if you
say what couldn't get me more nutrition
what's what can I eat that has more
nutrition that's very powerful because
then you get it stay out of trouble I
guarantee all the junk foods don't have
a lot of nutrition they don't other than
synthetic vitamins in politics you have
underlying principles that you use like
that I guess the principle in politics
or the underlying senior principle would
be something like on don't spend more
than you have right in the budget would
that be kind of a smart thing get out of
trouble so I guess we're not too worried
about that one just being sarcastic and
then you have what about in in the area
of health in general you have to or
health care you have to create your
health can you imagine if we just put 1
percent of then of the money we put in
sick care or health care into just
prevention or creating health it's over
it's over
I mean prevention the problem is the
doctors will say okay let's check in six
months okay and you keep coming back
let's check you let's check you sorry to
tell us you have cancer get your stuff
together and it's we're going to do
chemo what was to be done to prevent it
what was done to create the health
there's nothing what are they going to
do an aspirin a day I had to get life
insurance ok recent still trying to
figure well my wife I may get life
insurance
so I go to the doctor my cholesterol is
a 180 it's pretty good doctor says well
it's normal but we're going to prevent
we're going to we're going to practice
some preventive medication what what do
you talk about serum I goes I know but
we're just doing and everyone right now
I'm like no thank you
no because no no I have a free sample
lipitor I'm like now been assigned
effects cuz oh now that's you can't
believe the articles you can't believe
I'm like but I can get a kickback so the
point is that there's a lot of
corruption in the area of
pharmaceuticals and drugs you already
know that but the point is that you have
to start creating your health because
the doctors don't know how I trained
doctors I trained over 2,400 doctors
they're not taught how to get someone
healthy other than the food pyramid
drink more water eat more fiber you know
it's just like that's not significant so
you really have to learn how to create
health yourself and start building your
health because no one else is going to
do it for you
cancer takes 20 years to grow in your
body I mean all of you probably have
some cancer cells in your body it's what
you're doing in your environment that's
countering that right now to protect you
you literally you have to create your
health every day so I look at people a
little differently like what I'll do
when I'm listening to people I'll just
dissect them in half and I'll go okay
what are the things they're doing to
create their health and one of the
things are doing to counter create their
health because doing nothing is counter
creating right so and it's amazing it's
what makes it so simple I'm like wow
like wow look at this like you don't
have you don't realize that many people
don't realize that the cravings are a
very simple nutrient deficiency
potassium when you have low potassium
you will crave sugar guaranteed when you
get your daily amount of potassium you
will not crave sugar it's that simple
how many of the crave sugar okay if I
tell you what to do would you would you
do it to get rid of cravings within 24
hours or actually 48 hours okay so do
this thing right here normal amount of
potassium we need is 4700 milligrams a
day
now what food are is high in potassium
bananas right that's 400
okay how many bananas would it take
twelve twelve bananas right so you're
not going to do twelve bananas okay
so the amount of potassium you need is
so high you don't even realize it
there's a lot of potassium so what you
can do is you can have all the leafy
greens you would need seven cups to
seven cups it's not hard couple salads a
day and you will fulfill your daily
amount requirement for potassium you
won't you will not have cravings it's
wonderful to help protect against
diabetes this right here because when
you have that potassium and help
stabilize your blood sugars but how many
of you really don't consume to seven
cups of salad or day hardly anyone does
how the heck are you ever going to get
your potassium so this is the problem is
we don't really know what foods have the
right nutrients and and the soils are so
depleted if you would if you wanted to
get your basic nutrients of trace
minerals okay those are little minerals
that you need in small amounts in your
food right now with the soils the way
they are you would have to consume
27,000 calories of food yeah so that's
going to be pretty hard isn't it that's
a lot of food eating every day so you're
going to have to sub sort of enhance
your diet with something just make sure
it's the right nutrients plant-based you
have to concentrate but yeah that's this
is the problem is that people don't know
how to create health and so it's kind of
crazy so so we have the adrenal we have
with the problem with the adrenal is you
get fluid retention because all the
electrolytes are controlled the sodium
potassium is controlled by the adrenal
in other words when you have adrenal
problems you lose potassium your salts
and elect all these things that keep the
fluid moving are gone so the fluids
going to pull in your ankles when you
press your ankle that leaves a little
dent that's fluid retention you
shouldn't have that okay go ahead and
press your ankle and see if you have any
indentations there can you call 9-1-1
so fluid in the ankles is purely
electrolyte problem because the adrenal
it's backing up fluid so we had that
we're going to salt cravings for adrenal
to salt cravings
that's adrenal Sol is the is the mineral
that recharges the battery that's why
you need a little chip at night when you
go home I mean just to recharge your
battery because you're drained most of
you are like a car in the freeway the
battery is dead and you're putting gas
in the car why isn't this thing start
now you're pushing the car it's getting
kind of heavy so electrolytes fluid now
how much water should you drink a class
is right who told you that they told you
some day I'm going to find out and the
day is because that is a myth I was
taught to drink I still can't find the
where do you find this information only
drink when you're thirsty here's what I
found the more water you drink the more
dehydrated you become why because it
flushes out the electrolytes that are
supposed to hold the water there there's
a condition right now that I think it's
called hyponatremia which is actually
too much water which is flushing
electrolytes and you can die die by
drinking too much water so drink when
you're thirsty I have a machine I
measure fluid in person's body normally
people that drink the most water the
most dehydrated don't worry it gets
worse
so they is everywhere it's nowhere it's
like I don't know who they is so you
have fluids we have calcium calcium is
controlled by the adrenal not just bone
loss not just muscle cramps but you need
calcium to have to wind down at night
without good adrenals your calcium will
deposit not in the bone but on the bone
as arthritis bursitis tendinitis tartar
no teeth cataracts
kidney stones gall stones bursitis all
the itis is and twitching and the left
eyelid right here
yeah that's calcium so again what do
people take calcium carbonate limestone
it's in the one-a-days anytime you get a
vitamin that's prescribed prescription
at a pharmacy oh my goodness that's like
how low can you go it's just way off the
deep end it's just going to be rocks you
need plant-based minerals this is how it
works
the plant is supposed to break down the
minerals like rocks in earth and absorb
them into the plant and make them easy
to digest the plant-based minerals are
ten thousand times smaller than rocks
and metallic minerals that you would get
like sea salts
yeah ten thousand times smaller so that
would be the equivalent to a a golf ball
to the Empire State Building
so you absorb these plant-based minerals
so much better you find that when you
eat food you don't feel satisfied like
it just doesn't quite even water just
doesn't satisfy you because the
nutrients aren't there why do you think
you keep craving so it's just it's a
deficiency so we have sinus problems oh
that's another diagnosis sleep apnea
what does that mean it means that your
sinuses are blocked like very I mean
it's just amazing how it's gotten out of
control and so right now the answer to
healthcare is not spending more money on
it it's just to do more prevention the
whole philosophy is broken but there's
no money in prevention it's too cheap I
mean it's very cheap in fact I can take
every one of your grocery bills and
probably find a hundred dollars every
two weeks of a food that you could just
switch over to healthier food and just
in and just take that and create health
it's not that hard it's just choices
what to eat in the grocery store why do
I know this because I go in the grocery
store and I see what they have so bad
it's amazing like wow people must be
buying that because it's there I mean
trying to find food and grocery store
it's not easy um so we have adrenal any
other question about the adrenal body
type it's kind of an interesting type
snoring because the sinuses there's a
nerve that goes in the back of the
sinuses that if the adrenal gland
shrinks it because the cortisol and it
actually makes this thicker so you'll
like you know snoring so we have adrenal
now the other thing is that of course my
wife's is that sometimes I make that
sound like no I don't she goes ok I'm
going to record you I'm like ok you can
prove it
so that's adrenal